[Music]
Hong sang-soo's Chi won the Nobel Peace
Prize in 1991 at the time she was the
world's best known political prisoner
spending 15 years under house arrest
for standing against a military
dictatorship it was hoped she could
bring peace to Mayan ma formerly known
as Burma a country ravaged by civil war
after 25 years of repression
masucci's party won an election by a
landslide in 2015 a godmother she will
bring prosperity peace for everyone and
she has a big heart to treat everybody
equally
but Masucci failed to acknowledge the
plight of the row Hindu Muslim minority
who have been described as the most
persecuted on earth the Burmese army
have attack ro hinder villages burning
down buildings killing and raping as
they go why why nu is a row hinge a
Muslim whose father like ants and Suchi
was locked up for opposing the military
dictatorship in the 1990s
my father was put in jail for 47 years
along with his family members including
me I lost my future as a teenager I
never blamed my father or the movement
or dongseng sweetie she used to be my
hero but right now what we have seen her
positions against minority Andrew hinge
er it's it's break my heart there are 1
million row hinges living in Myanmar
most of whom are in Rakhine State
although row hinges have lived in the
country since pre-colonial times they
were stripped of their citizenship in
the 1980s they're the largest stateless
group of people in the world
Buddhists nationalists and the country's
army have targeted the RO hinder for
decades because of their religion
thousands of rural India have lost their
lives when dogs and soo-ji came into
power the revenger minority who were
very hopeful but then things get worse
since Masucci came to power the
persecution of the RO hinges has
increased strict laws govern their
movement and where they can live 120
thousand live in squalid camps as a
result of previous conflicts there has
been a lot of human rights abuses
for example sexual violence torture
arbitrary arrests after years of
persecution summer hinges are fighting
back forming a militia group the targets
military and police in Rakhine State in
August 2017 the group known as the era
Conroe hinge a Salvation Army attacked
police outposts the army responded with
brutality killing hundreds of ray hinges
prompting more than 150,000 to flee to
neighboring Bangladesh despite the
ongoing slaughter
mizuchi still won't mention the RO
hinder by name the Nobel Peace Prize
laureate has not even condemned the
violence often even defending the role
of the military in the face of the
growing humanitarian disaster an online
petition calling for Masucci to be
stripped of her Nobel Peace Prize has
been signed by over 300,000 people to
some extent and the sue Chi's hands are
tied the Constitution drafted by the
army gives her little control of the
security services and public opinion is
very hostile to the RO hinges this makes
it hard for her to have a real impact on
the situation
but she doesn't even speak out about the
religious suffering
[Music]
some people say she may have a reason
not to use the word hinder they have to
see Rominger as their people and they
have to treat them as other people in
the country as a leader who struggle for
democracy who had this passions of
promoting human rights and rule of law
she should take a firm position in
respecting minority rights Masucci came
to power on a promise of peace ending
conflict within the country and uniting
ethnic divisions but Mayan ma remains
wrapped by ethnic conflict at the very
least she should acknowledge the row
hinges suffering and call on the army to
end its bloodthirsty campaign